- We had to turn to the
federal government for help,
to state government for help.
I've stood in line
for government cheese.
I've stood in line for bread.
And I knew at 11 years old,
that that was not
America's best,
that there was more for us.
We didn't live that
way in Florida.
We didn't have to pay with
monopoly money for groceries
in the grocery store.
And that's what we
were doing in Colorado.
My stepdad, he ended up
getting work in Aspen
when I was about 12,
and we moved to the
Western Slope of Colorado.
And that really
was the best thing
that could've ever
happened to us.
We moved into a community
that wasn't just telling us
where to get a handout, but
they were offering a hand up.
(soft music)
- All right, I'm Dave Rubin,
and we are live in studio today
with the Congresswoman from
Colorado's third district,
Lauren Boebert, welcome
to "The Rubin Report."
- Thanks so much for
having me on Dave.
This is fantastic to actually
be in person with someone,
talking face-to-face,
imagine that.
- Face-to-face, we've got what?
About four feet between us?
- Yes. (laughs)
- Are we in any sort
of legal trouble?
Could this get you
kicked out of Congress?
What are we doing here?
- According to
political science,
we are in deep trouble
right now. (laughs)
- What about regular science?
I know political science,
we are in a lot of trouble.
- Yes.
I think we're okay with
regular science. (laughs)
- All right.
We got you all the way out
to crazy California.
- Yes.
- You're here for
a couple of days,
how do you feel in California?
You come from the, I would
say relatively free state
of Colorado, or the
ones really free state,
sort of hanging on.
- Yes, we are hanging on.
I do believe that there are
more conservatives in Colorado
than the average
person would know.
We are slowly turning
into California.
And really, it's been
quicker than any of us
would have liked to have seen.
But we have a governor
from California
who wants to mimic everything
that's happened here.
There's been documentaries
that have gone out,
the "Rocky Mountain Heist."
There's a book, "The
Colorado Blueprint."
And they were kind of
sounding the alarms
of what was happening,
and that Colorado
was really a petri dish for
all of these liberal policies
that Democrats want
to take nationwide.
And if they can
do it in Colorado,
they can do it
anywhere successfully.
And so that's what we're seeing.
And we didn't have any
voices in Colorado.
So I'm really happy to be
that loud voice in Colorado
right now, to let everyone know
what's happening to us there.
- Yeah, and I've done a
couple events in Colorado
over the last couple of
years, although unfortunately,
none in the last
year and a half,
but when I was on tour
with Jordan Peterson,
I went and a few other things.
And what I noticed when I
talked to a lot of people
was "Dave, Dave,
could you make sure
"all the California
people stop coming here?"
- Yes, yes.
- Are you still hearing
a lot about that?
- Yes, we still have
Californians coming,
and these political
refugees are bringing
their bad policies with them.
And so, that's really
devastating to our communities
because we like our
rural way of life,
and we don't want
that urban lifestyle.
Hey buddy!
- My dog has decided
to say hi. (laughs)
- Hi! (laughs)
I have dogs, I've goats
that bring so much joy.
- We are not editing this out,
but Clyde does have
to leave. (laughs)
- So sweet.
- Clyde!
Clyde just opened the door.
- Oh, hello.
- He's distracting
the congresswoman.
- You love me. (laughs)
- We could be in trouble here.
Well, we have the
outtake for the show.
Clyde, you gotta go now.
Guys, we have a tricked or a...
(Lauren laughs)
- [Man] Sorry!
- That brings me a lot of joy.
I love animals.
(crosstalk drowns the speakers)
Yes, wild. (laughs)
- Yeah.
So people are constantly
opening the door
and breaking into
your interviews.
I think, sorry, you were saying.
- That's fine. (laughs)
I dunno where we were, but
with everything that's...
Where were we?
- We were talking about
the Californians coming.
- Yes, and they're bringing
their bad policies with them.
And so there really is an
urban and rural divide,
and we want to keep
rural Colorado rural.
But unfortunately, in these
high mountain ski resort towns
that I represent,
a lot of Californians
can afford to move there,
and they're bringing
the same policies
that they're fleeing from.
- So I ask this to
every conservative or
Republican official
that I talk to, like
when the people come,
do you think they have
no idea that they voted
for those policies
that are now fleeing,
and realize that maybe they
should think about things
a little bit differently now?
- No.
Because their actions
would prove that,
they think they can flee
from their problems.
And unfortunately, there
is a lower class of people
who cannot afford to
flee those bad policies
that they have voted
in and implemented.
And so they get to leave,
pack up and go to somewhere
with lower taxes and
better opportunities,
and still have a
beautiful scenic view.
But there is another
class that's left behind
that can not afford to
make that same move,
and they're the ones who are
stuck in that terrible economy,
and a horrible state
where they are left now
to depend on the government
to help in their situations,
or even in these failing
economies where taxes
are just too high
to afford the homes
that they wanna live in.
So, it's really impacts
them more than anything.
And then they come
to these other states
and bring those same policies.
So I wouldn't think that
they knew what impact
they're having on
these communities.
- Yeah, the idea that
they're leaving the people
who can't afford to move
is sort of interesting too.
I realized this morning
when I was thinking
about how I wanted to
do this interview, that,
if you take sort of the new
crop of Congress people,
and you think about
mostly the Democrats side,
we all know
everything about AOC.
We know everything
about Ilhan Omar,
probably too much more
than we wanna know.
We know everything
about Ayanna Pressley,
and the rest of the crew,
but we don't actually
know that much
from a national
perspective about you.
And it's like, it
seems like people
should be talking
about you just as much,
but that's not really
how the media operates
'cause you're a
scary conservative.
- Scary conservative.
I should be the
Democrats dream story.
I was raised a Democrat, and
I was dependent on government.
And I thought I always would be,
because when you're stuck
in that cycle of poverty,
it's really hard to
break free of it.
- Yeah, can you tell everyone
your story a little bit?
- Yeah. Absolutely.
So I was born in
Orlando, Florida.
My mom was single, we
lived with her parents.
My grandparents, I attribute
a solid foundation to them,
and the few years that
they've had me in their home.
But my mom just up and
moved us to Colorado
when I was four years old.
She met a guy and moved
to an apartment in Aurora.
And I think her
pride was too big
to go back home to her parents.
Things kinda got a little rough.
He wasn't the prince charming
that she thought
he was going to be.
But then eventually, she
had my first younger brother
with him, and she didn't
want to have another child
not have a father.
And so, we were
stuck, we were here,
through the good, the
bad and the very ugly.
And that led us to times
where he wasn't working.
And we had to turn to the
federal government for help,
to state government for help.
I've stood in line
for government cheese.
I've stood in line for bread.
And I knew at 11 years old,
that that was not
America's best,
that there was more for us.
We didn't live that
way in Florida.
We didn't have to pay
with monopoly money
for groceries in
the grocery store.
And that's what we
were doing in Colorado.
My stepdad, he ended up
getting work in Aspen,
when I was about 12,
and we moved to the
Western Slope of Colorado.
And that really
was the best thing
that could've ever
happened to us.
We moved into a community
that wasn't just telling us
where to get a handout, but
they were offering a hand up.
And they started sharing with
my mom conservative values.
So she listened and even
changed her voter registration
to Republican, but she
didn't vote Republican.
- Well, that's a surprise.
- Yes, yes.
She got to the ballot box
and said, "No, I'm scared.
"I'll lose everything if
Republicans are in charge."
We didn't have enough
stability for her
to let go of that mindset.
And so, I started
working at 15 years old
at the Rifle McDonald's,
and I can still remember
bringing mom home
that first paycheck.
I remember the
dignity that had come
with earning a paycheck,
putting my hand to something
and creating wealth.
And that's something
that never left me.
I learned at a very young age
that I could do a better job
taking care of myself than
the government ever had.
So I began to develop these
conservative principles,
not even knowing
what was happening.
And my husband and I, we met
when he moved to Colorado
to work in the oil
and gas industry.
And, we knew that we could
build a great life together,
a successful life together.
I had only ever
wanted to be a mom.
I didn't have dreams
to be a business owner,
to be a doctor or a lawyer,
certainly not a politician.
I just wanted to be a mom.
My mom was my hero and
someone that I looked up to.
And so whenever we, when we
started our life together,
we wanted to start
our family right away.
And that left me with a very
difficult decision to make,
my senior year of high school,
'cause now I have a
child and a family,
and I didn't wanna go
back to the bread lines.
I didn't want government
cheese for my boy.
And so I quit high school,
and I took a management
position with McDonald's.
That was very good for my age,
and that was more valuable...
- Wait, they took you
into a management position
after quitting high
school, just like that?
- Yes.
- Wow.
- Yes, no degree
necessary. (laughs)
- Wow.
Wow. (laughs)
- Yes.
Well, it was really...
It was the hours
that I needed to work
for that shift manager position
of why I needed to
quit high school.
I was working nights
with them, and they said,
"To be a shift manager, we
need you in this day shift."
And so I had to leave high
school to take on that role.
And for me, there was more
value in earning that paycheck
for my family than
sitting in geography class
for another two months until
I graduate high school.
- Do you remember what
you were making per hour,
at that point?
- 45 a year.
- 45 A year?
- 45,000 a year.
- Yeah.
Oh, that's once you were
in the manager position.
But do you remember what
you were making per hour
at McDonald's before that?
- About 7.50.
There was several
different pay periods
that I had with them.
I started out, I
think at 6.15 an hour,
and then I was
about 7.50 an hour.
And then I went to
a salaried position.
- How much of that
shapes your economics,
the way you think about it now?
Because to be a good person,
I thought we have to
have everyone making,
or the lowest people
have to make $15.
That means you're a
good moral person.
If you scream that,
should you have been
making $15 an hour then?
- No, I worked for every
extra dollar that I did earn.
And it really gave
me an opportunity
that I wouldn't have had
if minimum wage was $15.
Look at how many things
are automated now?
Now that we're
reaching $15 per hour,
McDonald's has kiosks instead
of the 15, 16, 17 year old
high school student
that was coming in
and earning a paycheck.
And so I would not have
had the opportunities
that have shaped my
worldview, my economic view
had minimum wage been so high,
because they would not
have been able to afford
to invest in me and provide
that opportunity for me
to have a work ethic and
develop my life skills.
- So I actually didn't know
that part of your story,
but it's a pretty
perfect through line
to you own a restaurant now.
- Yes, yes I do.
- So, you were doing something
right back in high school
at McDonald's?
- Yes, I'm a very
spontaneous person by nature.
Sometimes I see it as
my greatest downfall,
but sometimes it
works out pretty well.
And I ended up
leaving McDonald's,
and I went into the oil and
gas industry for awhile.
I was filing some papers
at a local company,
and then decided to go out
in the field and do work,
and I was a pipeline technician.
So locating pipeline,
doing cathodic protection
without an engineering degree.
It's possible to do work without
a four-year college degree.
And so I was locating pipelines.
I was GPSing the pipelines,
making maps to them,
doing cathodic protection,
which is we install
anodes to protect
the pipe from corroding.
And so it was just this
fascinating part of my job
that I loved and got to
drive all around the valley,
and hike up and down mountains,
locating these pipes and making
sure they were protected.
And then the oil
and gas industry
started to be heavily regulated.
Colorado saw the
industry pulling out.
So a lot of us, our
days were numbered.
I ended up leaving and decided
to be a stay-at-home mom.
I had three boys then and said,
I'm gonna just be with
my boys for awhile.
And unfortunately, a little
bit later, it got worse.
And so my husband ended up
running out of contracts,
and he wasn't working
in the industry anymore.
And we said we needed a plan B.
There was a local
restaurant that shut down,
and it was one of our favorites.
It was called The Cowboy
Calf-A, C-A-L-F dash A.
- Ah, got it, got it.
- Yes, and they closed down
and they had a for rent
sign in the window.
And we drove by one
day and said, maybe,
maybe we could do this.
And so we went in, it was a
great deal to lease the place,
the equipment was there.
And we decided whenever
he went back to work
to start investing his
paycheck into the restaurant
and opening it up.
Very spontaneous, never
owned a restaurant before,
but I wanted a way to
give back to my community.
A lot of our friends
were unemployed,
and they needed
opportunity again.
And that opportunity
wasn't there
in the oil and gas
industry like it had been.
And so we opened up, we
hired our waitresses,
our kitchen staff,
and we were just a
Western-themed restaurant
wanting to give excellent
service to our community.
And it was a pretty great place.
When we first opened, I
didn't have a lot of money.
I didn't have any
money for advertising.
So we went door to door on
the first day to each business
and said, hey, come in and
have a free meal on us.
And that was cheaper than any
advertising I could have done.
And it worked, people liked
it, and they were coming back.
So what you may have heard
about the restaurant,
a few weeks after we opened
our Western-themed restaurant,
there was an altercation where
a man was brutally beaten
outside of the restaurant.
Show up in the morning, there's
crime scene tape everywhere,
there's police officers.
I was talking with some of
the officers that I knew
asking what had happened.
And there was a man who
was beaten pretty badly,
and he ended up losing his life.
And so that immediately
prompted the question to me,
how am I gonna take
care of everyone?
How am I going to protect the
people that are around me?
So, I went across the street,
and talked to a local gun
dealer, a gun salesman,
and I asked him about
Colorado's carry laws.
And he said, "Well, you can
carry openly without a permit."
So that's what I did.
I began to open carry.
Soon after that, my waitresses
began to open carry.
And the next thing you know,
Shooters Grill was being called
the safest restaurant
in America.
- Shooters Grill, so
there is the name.
And there have been no shootings
at Shooters Grill?
- No.
- People are not
murdering each other
or anything like that?
- No.
- It's interesting because
you mentioned at the top
that your story, the
Democrats should sort of love
your story, but in a way, I
get why they hate your story.
You came from nothing,
you worked hard,
you did a bunch of stuff.
You kept growing, you
care about family.
- Right.
- That's a problem for them.
- Yes.
- They can't have
the success story.
- Right.
They are okay with you
turning a blind eye
to their failures.
If the man in The
White House has a son
who's lost three laptops,
and is addicted to
smoking Parmesan cheese,
we can turn a blind eye to that.
If a CNN analysis gets caught
doing some very, very
horrendous, inappropriate things
on a Zoom meeting, then that's
okay as long as he comes on
and says, "I'm sorry."
But no, that real life,
when things get tough,
you get tougher, and you
make success out of failures.
You learn from your
mistakes and you continue.
You don't let that hold
you back or keep you down,
and you offer to other
people a way to have success
in their lives.
That is what they hate.
- So when did you decide,
"Okay, I've got these ideas,
"my life's in order now,
restaurant's working
"and got the family, let
me get into politics,"
of all things?
(Dave and Lauren laugh)
"Let me throw that all away."
- Right.
Well, being in the restaurant,
a lot of people come in,
they're complaining about
the issues of the day.
I think you and I could probably
relate with being involved
in Republican politics,
because we're both
kind of new to that.
I voted Republican, but
I wasn't paying attention
to who I was voting for,
why I was voting for them,
and what happened in
between those elections.
And so I'm actually fairly
new to that process.
I just know, as
a business owner,
they were affecting my business.
They were affecting my family.
They were affecting
the paychecks
that we were able to bring home.
I was electing people who I
thought had my same views,
but then they would
get to Washington DC
or to The State
Capitol, overregulate,
over tax, overspend
and destroy everything that
we're trying to build at home.
And so, we talk about that
kinda stuff in the restaurant.
And I really believe that a
lot of our problems in America
is because we had an entire
generation at least say,
you're not allowed to talk
about religion or politics.
And now we have an entire
generation that is ignorant
about the things of
God and government.
And you're not allowed
to have that...
- They've made politics
religion, basically.
- Yes, yes, exactly.
That is their God,
government is their God.
And that's why they believe
that government can come in
and rule you and
you need to submit,
and they can take
rights away from you
because they are the
granter of those rights.
- [Dave] Speaking my language.
- Yes. (laughs)
Yes.
And so, in my restaurant,
you're free to talk
about those things,
even if you disagree with me.
Freedom of speech is so
under attack right now,
and if we lose that,
we lose everything.
Hate speech is free speech.
Speech that you disagree
with is free speech.
And this is something
that we have to protect.
So this isn't just a
Second Amendment issue
or a 10th Amendment
issue, this is everything,
our livelihoods and
everything moving forward.
We know what Big Tech is doing
to sensor freedom of speech.
And really, it's the first
time in history that Big Tech,
somewhat an entity this
big is more of a threat
than big government,
because this is someone
playing the role of government
in your life and
taking things from you.
It's bizarre.
But I didn't wanna
just sit and complain
about what was going on.
I wanted to be a
part of the solution.
And I didn't know
what that meant,
but suddenly there was this
suave pretty boy from Texas,
who got up on a
presidential debate stage,
(Dave laughs)
and he slipped up.
Beto O'Rourke told the whole
world what Democrats plan to do
with your Second Amendment.
He said, "Hell yes, we're
gonna take your AR 15s
"and your AK 47s."
So, I got pretty upset,
and I drove to his
presidential rally.
My husband said,
"What are you doing?
"That's three hours away.
"We don't have the fuel, the
extra gas money to do that."
And I said, no, I'm
gonna talk to this guy.
And he said, "You just
think they're gonna let you
"talk to him?"
It's like, I don't know, but
I'm going, very spontaneous.
And so I drove three hours
to his presidential rally,
with my Glock on my hip.
And I looked him in
the eye and told him,
hell no, you're not.
And I was just so frustrated,
and millions of Americans
were just as frustrated as me.
And they were reaching out
to me saying, "Thank you.
"This is exactly what we felt."
And I said, who is
speaking up for them?
And if me, just a mom of four
boys from Rifle, Colorado,
a restaurant owner, can
say something so impactful
that the nation listens,
what else could I do
to help bring awareness
to what's happening,
and hold these people
accountable and try to make
a bad situation right?
So a couple of months later,
I decided to run
for this position.
Took on a five term incumbent,
and everyone told me,
"You can't do this.
"You will lose."
And we were outspent 10 to one.
I won by 10 points,
and it's because I had
the people support.
I have a very large
district in Colorado,
nearly half the state,
and I have driven
every bit of it,
and connected with thousands
and thousands of people,
and I love them.
I love seeing them over
and over and over again,
and connecting with them
and hearing from them.
And it's just such an
honor to be their voice.
- So you're kind of
appreciative of Beto.
I assume if it wasn't
for him to say,
everyone remembers that moment.
Like if it wasn't for him saying
something so profoundly
ridiculous, you are not doing
what you're doing.
- It would've never opened
the door for this, exactly.
I wouldn't have had
anyone to yell at.
- (chuckles) So, okay.
So you get to the Capitol, and
you're part of this new crop
of people, and there's all
these young Progressives,
and they're on the
cover of every magazine
and everyone's telling them
they're all so wonderful,
they're so perfect
and everything,
but they don't
include you in that.
They don't include
Dan Crenshaw in that.
Somehow you guys are,
actually you're basically
framed as the bad guys.
- [Lauren] Right.
- Can you talk a little bit
about just how the media reacts
to you guys more
than anything else?
- Yes, well, I was a
little prepared for it
coming into Congress because
during the general election,
the media spent over $5
million trying to make me look
like a monster, an
absolute criminal.
I have a mugshot
because I didn't pay
a hundred dollar traffic ticket.
It's paid now.
- Oh, lord!
- But you go in, you get your
pretty little picture taken,
(Dave laughs)
and you pay the hundred
bucks and you leave.
Billboards everywhere,
plastered with my mugshot.
And, "This law breaker
wants to be your lawmaker."
and all of this...
- Oh, that's clever.
- Yes. (laughs)
Pretty, pretty clever.
I would take selfies with the
billboards when I'd see them,
like, hey, it's better than
my driver's license picture,
but...(laughs)
- But then you get there,
and then you see the reaction
that they're
getting, everyone...
Because basically, the
leadership of the Democrats
seem like they handed them
the keys to the castle,
and the inmates are
running the asylum.
But you guys, nobody's really
talking about you guys.
- Right.
No, they want us to be quiet.
They want to demonize us and
make us look to be the enemy.
Nancy Pelosi has called
me the enemy within.
We have metal detectors outside
of the House Chambers
because of me.
And so it seems.
- So that was because you said
you were gonna carry there,
and she basically was
like, "No, you're not.
"So we're gonna..."
Yeah.
- Yes.
- And then whatever
happened because of that.
So that you have
to walk through?
- Right, the metal detectors,
or you're fined $10,000.
$10,000 if you refuse to go
through the metal detector,
personal money.
So, I have my firearm
everywhere in the Capitol,
in the office, except
for the House Chambers.
It's permitted for me to
be everywhere, but there,
and so she put up
the metal detectors
right outside the
House Chambers.
I can go in the
Senate Chambers now,
that's a little more
free over there.
- Oh that's free?
- Yes.
- Oh okay, she's not
in charge of that.
- Right, exactly, exactly.
And so, if you've ever
been in the rotunda,
you'll see the statue of Reagan.
And if you look closely, there's
pieces of the Berlin Wall
in that statue, it's
embedded in that statue.
And I think somewhere
right there in the middle
of the rotunda and the Capitol,
is some sort of magic wall.
Maybe it's like the Berlin
Wall, because on one side,
it's pure authoritarian tyranny,
and then the other side,
it's kind of free. (laughs)
- Sort of a metaphor
for America, I suppose,
where the states kinda
go their different ways.
So the media doesn't
treat you guys that great.
But what about, I've
been talking a lot about,
on the show lately, about
motives, and it's like,
do these people really know
the damage they are doing?
And I think a lot
of people think
that their constituents don't.
Their constituents kinda think,
"Oh no, they're
trying to do good."
I'm kinda past the point where
I think that their motives
are good because they're
doing so much damage.
Have you had sit downs, AOC,
Ilhan, the rest of them.
Have you had sit
downs with Nancy?
Like, what do you think
is really going on there?
- So I've not had
sit downs with them
because they keep us so
divided and so separate.
And previous,
members of Congress
who have been there previously,
they'll tell you it's
never been this way.
There was always communication
between Republicans
and Democrats.
And now it is so divided,
and that's by design.
She wants to keep us separate.
She wants the House
Chambers empty.
- You're talking about Nancy?
- Nancy Pelosi, yes, yes.
And she truly believes
this is Pelosi's house,
not the people's house.
And so even in the
House Chambers, she
wants us masked up.
It's a $2,500 fine if
we're not wearing our mask,
but that's only where the
C-SPAN cameras are rolling.
- Right.
- It's political theater.
- So you know for a fact, this
is not, you're not making it,
they're not wearing their
masks in their offices,
with their staff or
when they are going out?
- Right, I see them
walking in the halls.
As soon as they
leave the chambers,
they're taking off their masks.
I've seen AOC start to
film a selfie video,
which I later saw on Instagram,
and I knew exactly where she
was and where she was doing it.
And she put on her
mask and then pretended
to take it off for the video.
It's political theater.
We've all seen her
on the Capitol Steps,
"Oh, we're going to take a
picture, put on your mask."
I mean, it's nuts.
And so we have a complete
invasion at our Southern border,
and Americans are being punished
with these COVID policies,
this Fauci-funded Chinese
virus, that is absolutely
affecting every part of
our lives, our children.
I just pulled my kids
out of public school
because they brought
back mask mandates,
and they're not
letting up on it.
And I said, okay, well,
we're doing something else,
because I'm not subjecting
my children to this again.
And so we're pulling them out
and doing something
on our own, but...
- Are you homeschooling now?
- It will be a hybrid version
of homeschooling, yes.
And I need help for that.
I believe in this country,
and I believe that we
have an opportunity
to get things back on path.
And if I didn't believe that,
I wouldn't leave my four boys
every single day to
do what I'm doing,
but I want them to
have a good future.
I have been here from the
beginning to make sure my boys
never have to live in
a socialist nation.
Their freedom is my motivator.
And that's why I'm stepping
up to do what I can
to serve our country.
And so there's so
much that's happening.
I was at a Columbus Day event
and we found an immigrant
that Democrats hate, and
it's Christopher Columbus.
- (laughs) And we
finally found why.
- Yes.
And it's interesting, 'cause
there was a couple of dozen
protesting my speech
in Christopher
Columbus, but it said,
if you want to
protest immigration,
go to the Southern border.
This is an invasion
that's taking place.
You're calling Christopher
Columbus a rapist.
I've seen the rape trees
at the Southern border.
I've been there three times.
Women's undergarments hung
from them as trophies.
I've seen the young
unaccompanied minors,
the young teenage girls that
have empty Plan B packaging
in their backpacks because
their mothers sent them
on that journey with
the Plan B pill,
expecting them to be
sexually assaulted.
This is a crisis.
And unfortunately this regime
won't do anything about it.
I think they're sitting back
and saying, "Mission
accomplished."
That's what it...
- So do you think
it's that bad that...
I think 10 years ago there
were a lot of Republicans
or conservatives that were like,
"The socialists are
kinda coming here,
"that's really what
we're fighting."
And I think most
people are like,
"Ah, you guys are kinda nuts.
"You're all on Republican,
"conservative talk
radio or something."
And now it seems
kind of obvious.
That's what I mean
about the motives.
Like I sort of don't
blame the 18 year old kid
who's confused, but I do blame
now I would say The Squad
and Pelosi and Biden,
not that I think he's
really in charge,
and you're welcome to
comment on that too.
But like, are they
just accomplishing
what they want to accomplish?
Like we shouldn't be saying,
oh no, no, they're
trying to do good.
- I do believe that
they're accomplishing
exactly what they
want to accomplish.
I was talking with Lee Zeldin,
Congressman from New York
running for governor, and I
think he explained it perfectly.
He said, "If you
were able to actually
"look into some of these
Squad members hearts."
If you were to look into
Rashida Tlaib, Ilhan Omar,
it's probably gonna be
pretty black and evil,
and they are accomplishing
everything that they want.
But if you were able to take
a peek into AOC's heart,
you're probably gonna find
rainbows and unicorns.
(Dave and Lauren laugh)
And she really just wants
everything to be cheerful,
and if we just pay
for everything and
provide everything
to everyone, the world
will be wonderful.
And that's not the way it works.
So I do believe that there
are different motives,
but unfortunately they're
all going the same direction.
And it's a direction that
we are trying to stop.
We just want people to be free.
It is not the proper role
of government to keep people
healthy, to keep them safe in
every aspect of their life.
If so, we wouldn't
let people drive cars.
We would have somebody
assigned to them to make sure
they're crossing the
street correctly.
There's so many things
that we would do
to make sure that everyone
is safe, all the time.
- You wouldn't let
people drink soda.
- Soda, yes.
- As simple as that.
- Yes, yes, exactly.
And so with all of this,
we want people to be free.
That is the proper
role of government.
Our founding fathers,
they had such an
amazing spirit of faith.
They declared the end
from the beginning.
They wanted to be independent.
They wanted to be freed from
an oppressive tyrannical king.
And they declared that
independence before they had it.
They celebrated that freedom
before they were free.
And then they went and fought
that battle for 11 more years
until they obtained it.
And then they crafted
the Constitution,
the most amazing document,
to ensure that we
keep these freedoms,
that government is
instituted to secure
the rights of the people,
that we the governed give
consent to be governed.
And there's a lot that we're
not consenting to anymore.
- So is any of it
working right now?
I agree with everything you
just said obviously, but like,
is any of it at any
level working right now,
when Biden comes out every day,
and we're not gonna
respect state's rights?
And Saki says,
"It's unquestionable
"that the federal
government has more power,
"the power to override the
states and everything."
I was like, what?
Like what part of this
thing is working right now?
- This is a question that I
ask every day, because no,
it's not, because they're
completely ignoring it.
They are going against
the Constitution,
breaking their oaths to defend
and secure the Constitution
on a daily basis, and overriding
the rights of the people
through executive orders.
When I sit on an
airline and I hear
that there is a
federal law that says
that you have to
wear a mask and say,
well, gosh, I'm a
federal law maker,
and I don't remember
making that law.
I don't remember
voting on that law.
But this is the overreach
of the Democrat Party,
and I think a lot of people
are waking up to that.
Certainly, I don't think
that this is a president
that obtained 81 million votes.
I think he would have a
little bit of confidence
in his base to at
least answer questions
if this was such a
popular president.
But I mean that's neither
here nor there, but I,
I objected to the
Electoral College results
because the Constitution
was violated.
And that's our biggest
threat right now,
is the complete disregard
of the Constitution
of the United States.
You could go and try to
find votes in Arizona,
votes in Georgia, whatever,
hundreds of thousands of votes,
ballots were mailed
out right in our faces
against State Constitutions
and the Federal Constitution.
- Meaning because we
changed procedures
because of COVID, basically.
- Right. Exactly.
Because the state
legislature has the right
to change election laws.
And in six states in particular,
it was not the state
legislatures that did that.
No legislator passed
a law like that.
We had rogue judges,
attorneys, generals,
secretaries of states
and unelected bureaucrats
changing election laws.
And so, that's the big,
that's what everyone's
missing right there.
That is why me and
146 other Republicans
objected in January.
And then this has just
been spun out of control,
and we gotta find
10,000 ballots,
20,000 ballots.
No, hundreds of thousands
were mailed out illegally,
right in front of your faces.
- What percentage
of your constituents
do you think care about this?
Because I can tell you after
this, California recalled it,
obviously it didn't go
the way that I wanted to.
Before and after, almost
everybody that I spoke to,
and I campaigned
with Larry Elder,
almost everyone that I spoke to,
we might literally be
everyone I spoke to
during the campaign
said, "Dave, do you trust
"what's gonna happen
with the results?"
Which they're already,
that's their way of saying,
"I don't trust what's gonna
happen with the results."
So now we've got like
this almost parasite
in the system now
of belief or lack of belief.
- Yes.
And that is very
concerning because it,
I would say high 90s, high 90%
of the folks that follow me
and are voting don't have
trust in our elections.
And I think there's been a
distrust for a long time,
but this is the most blatant
in your face form of distrust.
And this is something that
we have to keep communicating
to people to show up and vote.
I don't think that it
helps any of us to say,
"Oh, well, stay home."
That doesn't help our country,
but we have to have states
securing their election laws
and making it easy to
vote and hard to cheat.
We have to keep that pressure
on the states to do that.
I can't guarantee that
Colorado will be changing
their election
laws anytime soon,
with our Democrat
super majority.
But in these other states,
where they have the opportunity
to do something,
like Georgia, do it,
it's strengthen that.
And give confidence
back to your voters.
- How do you guys fight
the messaging though?
Because I covered all
the election laws,
the Georgia stuff,
the Texas stuff, there
was nothing racist in it.
There was nothing against
causing anyone to vote.
These were things to make
election safer, an ID,
you have to show an ID
when you rent a golf club,
a mini golf, like basic things.
But the messaging all is
that you guys are racist
and you don't want
people to vote,
and you're stealing elections.
Like how do you beat that thing?
- If there's anything that's
racist, it's vaccine passports,
because there's actually a...
- Which you have to show
an ID to get a vaccine.
- Right. Exactly.
Yes, yes, you have to show
an ID to get a vaccine.
And then even in
places like New York,
it's more difficult to sit
down in a restaurant and eat,
than it is to cross our
Southern border illegally.
- Correct!
- This is absurd.
So if they wanna talk about
identification being racist,
well, let's flip it
right back on them
and talk about these
vaccine mandates
that are coming from
The White House.
This is something that is
affecting people's livelihoods.
I'm so proud of the nurses
that have taken a stand,
the Southwest pilots
that have taken a stand.
I know United had a
victory with a judge
that put a pause on this.
- Wait, wait, are you telling
me that it wasn't just weather
that delayed those Southwest?
I heard Joe Biden, he
said it was just weather.
It wasn't just weather?
- Maybe it was Hurricane
Brandon, I don't know.
- Ah, it was Hurricane Brandon.
It was definitely
that Brandon Guy.
- Yes.
- But even that, the
way they blatantly lie.
We all see what's
happening on Twitter.
- You can look at
the weather radar.
- And somehow, could the
weather only affect one airline?
Is that possible?
- Just one.
Just one.
Yes, other airlines
had 2% of their flights
that were canceled.
It's absolutely absurd.
- But what do you do with that?
I keep driving home to
this point, but like,
that seems to me the
bigger issue than just
that they can lie and
get away with lies,
and call you the
liar, and me the liar,
and all of our audience the
liar, when they're always lying.
But it seems to be working.
- Yes.
We have to have
conversations like this.
Joe Rogan just confronted
CNN about taking
a so-called horse
medicine, horse dewormer.
And he's like,
"No, you said this.
"Your company who you work
for said this, CNN said it,
"and you didn't stop him."
"Oh yeah, maybe that was bad."
"No, no, no, but
you didn't stop it."
And that's what we have to do.
We have to continue to call
them out on what they're doing.
Look, they've lied about
me from the beginning.
They said that I
led a reconnaissance
tour, January 5th.
Okay, I don't even think I was
in the Capitol January 5th.
And January 2nd, I brought
my family into the Capitol,
as a member elect with a
Capitol Hill police officer.
I had my four boys,
my son, my mom,
my husband and my mom.
I'm sorry, sometimes
he's like my son.
(Dave and Lauren laugh)
And we're looking
at this Capitol,
that I'm about to be sworn
in as a member of Congress,
and Steve Cohen, chairman
of the bad hair caucus
from Tennessee, he sees us
in the hall, waves at us,
and then goes on CNN
and says I was leading
a reconnaissance tour.
And they are able to lie
and get away with this.
And this is something my
family has been attacked for,
received death threats over.
My mom has received death
threats and even filed a lawsuit
against a very
notable influencer.
He said that she was the
bullhorn lady, on January 6th.
And the bullhorn lady, there's
this woman with a pink cat,
and she's got a bullhorn,
and she's yelling,
and she's like giving
directions for people.
We can't even find the
bathrooms in the Capitol.
Like we can lead a
reconnaissance tour
and give people directions.
And so you're right, they're
able to lie all the time,
and they absolutely
get away with it.
And we have to be there
to expose the truth.
I think everyone, we're
created to recognize truth.
And so if we keep
putting that out there,
more people will
gravitate to that truth.
You did, I did.
- Yeah, no, believe
me, it's the only way
I could do what I
do for a living.
If you didn't believe
that the truth matters,
then I don't know how you
could wake up and fight
in Congress or talk about
politics for a living.
You'd basically go crazy.
But then the other
piece of that,
which you sort of referenced
already is the Big Tech piece,
obviously, which is now, it's
not only that they can lie,
but their lies get
injected with steroids,
and our truth gets actually
cut off at the knees,
because they won't let
certain things get out.
Now it's even worse,
what do we do about that,
miss congresswoman?
- Oh man.
(Dave laughs)
Well, I need a majority
to do something,
because Republicans aren't
gonna be able to fix this
in the minority.
There's no Democrat
that's gonna say,
"Yeah, Republicans
need a platform.
"They need to have
this censorship removed
"so they could have
more likes on Twitter."
And it's so funny, we try
to get something trending.
We have the followers,
but they don't see it.
And then just after
seven minutes,
Lauren Boebert is so dumb
would trend number one
all day long, (laughs)
because it's allowed
to, because they let it.
And so, it's okay, I have
fun with that stuff too.
I'm not dumb enough to think
that $7 trillion equals zero,
so try again.
(Dave chuckles)
- Wait a minute, so
you're saying if you
spend $3.5 trillion
that doesn't equals zero?
- Yeah, it doesn't equal zero.
It doesn't equal zero
- I'm gonna have to check
my numbers over there.
- Gosh. Yes.
- But that's another one,
they are just everything.
Lying and everything.
- There are antitrust
laws for this reason.
So these big companies, these
big bullies can't suppress
the little guys like
they did with Parler,
that was getting
too big for them.
And we have to be
in the majority
to be able to do something.
I know Jim Jordan is
working on legislation,
and I think that's where
it's going to take place.
I think judiciary is going
to get to the bottom of this,
and we're going to have
some effective legislation
to make sure
Section 230 is gone,
or at least these
companies are broke up,
whatever that means.
I keep hearing they're
gonna break them up.
I don't know exactly
what that looks like.
But to break them up, remove
the liability protection
and make them accountable,
either they're a publisher,
or they're a platform,
you have to choose one.
You don't get to be both.
- Yeah, are you worried?
Obviously we've talked
about this a lot,
but are you worried
that if you remove 230,
that in essence they've
lose the protections
and then they're just gonna
crack down on speech more,
because they're gonna be liable,
and then they're gonna be like,
"All right, we gotta
get rid of everything."
- That is absolutely a worry,
and that's why you haven't
seen just a blanket removal
of Section 230.
I think that's why you
didn't see President Trump
do away with Section 230,
because there are details
like these that we
need to look into.
But I'm really grateful
that we have the Jim Jordans
of the world that are
looking into this.
Judiciary, that
entire committee,
there are brilliant
minds serving there.
And they just need the
numbers to be able to get
their agenda passed.
They need to be able
to get that out there,
because right now
everything is party lines.
Even something as simple as
removing a $200 million earmark
for the Presidio in
Nancy Pelosi's district,
that's straight
down party lines.
Democrats says, "No,
no, she's the speaker.
"She deserves a little extra."
- And she should get a
little extra ice cream
in her twin Z fridge
and all that stuff.
Do you ever think when you're
at some of these hearings,
like at this point when I watch,
especially the
Big Tech hearings,
I watch them and Jim
Jordan does do a great job,
and I've talked to him about it.
But when I watch these
hearings, it sort of feels
like we're just watching a movie
that we've all seen before.
Yes, Zuckerberg will
say some nice things,
and some things we disagree
with, the whistleblower,
this whistleblower who
really is a lefty activist,
will sort of say
some nice things,
but then also became
like a policy advocate
for government intervention.
That it's just like,
there's a lot of talk.
It's a lot of talk, it's
sort of interesting.
It's on mobile and
then it's kind of like,
ah, nothing ever really matters,
'cause the next day he
starts and there we go.
- Right, because the
Democrats won't allow
any progress to be made.
And they are in the majority.
Congress is a
majority rule body.
We are a self-governing
So Congress makes its own
rules for what happens
in those chambers, in
those committee hearings.
And the majority
has the final say.
You have leader McCarthy
who has offered up
privilege resolutions
to remove someone
who can't get a civilian
security clearance
from the Intel
Committee, Eric Swalwell,
but he's allowed to have this
security clearance in Congress
on the Intel Committee, and
they won't even hear it.
They table the motion.
They said, "No, no, we're
not even discussing this."
- So I had McCarthy in
here telling me just that.
In essence, Swalwell
was sleeping with a spy.
Like that's pretty much what
happened and everyone knows it,
and Nancy basically said
to him, "I don't care."
But he can get away with
it because he's a Democrat.
- That's right. That's right.
As long as you have that
D next to your name,
that you're, yes.
It's amazing what you
could get away with.
But that's why we do
hear a lot of talk
because in the minority,
that's what we have right now.
We have our talk.
Our job is to get in
the Democrats' way,
and then come home,
and tell our constituents how
we're getting in their way.
We're exposing
what they're doing,
so that when we
have that majority,
we are able to hold
them accountable.
We are able to do something.
And everybody likes to
go back to 2017, 2018
when Republicans had
it all and did nothing.
But forget that, that's why
people like me are here.
That's why Kat Cammack
from Florida is here,
and Mary Miller from
Illinois and Madison Cawthorn
from North Carolina, Beth
Van Duyne from Texas,
Ronny Jackson from Texas.
We have such an
incredible freshman class,
and we are here because
we looked at that majority
and we're frustrated.
So what are you guys doing?
So we need that back,
so we can actually
accomplish something.
We were all pretty confident
we were gonna take
the house back,
and we would be able
to bring home victories
to our districts, but we
don't have those numbers.
We're five short right now.
So we need people to show
up in the next election
and make sure we are in a
position to actually put action
behind our words, to
do something about
what we're saying.
- How worried are you though,
that this movie has
been played before?
And you're the young
crop now, and you come in
and you're like, "We're gonna
change the whole damn thing,
"and we're gonna do all the
stuff that nobody else did."
But then five years go by,
you get reelected once, twice.
Now you're in it for
awhile, and then it's like,
the swamp seems to just
envelope everybody.
- Right.
And I have seen that, but
I have a secret weapon.
So I am a proud member
of The Freedom Caucus,
and there's about
40 of us right now.
And it's incredible.
These are the members of
Congress who are there
for the right reasons.
These are your Mark
Meadows, your Jim Jordans,
your Andy Biggs.
And they are the movers
and shakers, and the ones
who aren't going to bow down
just because leadership says,
"This is what we're doing."
These are the folks that
will vote against leadership
because it's unconstitutional,
because it goes against
their principles
and the promises that
they made to their people.
So if we have a 40 to
50 person voting bloc
in the majority, we have
an ability to have a voice
in what's happening in
the Republican party.
And that voting bloc is
very, very important.
I do believe leadership
gets it more than they have
in the past, and I hope that
they stay in that direction.
But we can't do things
the way we always have.
So being a member of The Freedom
Caucus is so valuable to me
because we actually debate the
constitutionality of anything
that we're going to
take a position on.
We debate the
constitutionality of procedures
that take place.
We are the ones that are...
- But it's that the
problem at some level?
- Yeah.
- I'm with you,
why it's right and good,
and all of those
things, of course,
but they're not doing that.
Pelosi or AOC you mentioned
before she got rainbows
and unicorns in her
head, she's not walking
into any of those things and
talking to Ilhan and be like,
"We've gotta figure out the
constitutionality of this.
"Well, let's do it."
- Right. Yes.
- Is that a asymmetrical war
that is almost unwinnable?
- Well, you look at The Squad,
and they're kind of the
opposite of The Freedom Caucus.
But they are like The
Progressive Caucus.
They're in the Democrat Party,
and they have a check
on Nancy Pelosi.
She can't pass
the infrastructure
bill without them.
So instead, she's looking to
Moderate Republicans saying,
"Help us pass this
infrastructure bill."
- Right.
I take it, no
one's jumping over.
- Yes.
- Yes, no one's jumping over?
- No, there are
Republicans jumping over.
And your viewers need to
know it, and they need
to be calling all of these
Moderate Republicans,
the ones who voted
for impeachment,
the ones who voted to remove
a, voted with Democrats
to remove a Republican from
her committee assignments.
They need to be calling
these people and saying,
"Do not pass the
infrastructure bill.
"The $1.5 trillion
infrastructure bill,
"because that is the catalyst
for the $5.5 trillion
"budget reconciliation."
It's not 3.5, it's
not 4.3, it's 5.5.
- But it's all zero,
also at the same time.
- All zero though.
- But wait, just to be clear,
as of us taping
this at this moment,
I don't think there's anyone
publicly that is doing it.
But you're saying that there
are talks behind the scenes,
and that some Republicans
likely will break.
What do they see as
the win for that?
It's just that people, they
like being pet Republicans.
Like they like
being pet, on MSNBC.
- They're in really
tough districts.
So they have to bring home
the bacon for their districts,
and that means voting
with Democrats.
But we can put forward a
really good alternative.
In fact, I have.
I'm all for
infrastructure, we all are.
President Trump, I think
he had a $5 trillion
infrastructure plan.
That was like pretty extreme,
but he wanted to work with
Democrats on infrastructure.
I have an infrastructure bill,
the American Infrastructure
Modernization Act, the IM Act,
$650 billion, which is more
that's currently allocated
for infrastructure
in their bill.
And...
- Because everything's
infrastructure?
- Right, everything.
Yes, your mind it's the most
important infrastructure
they're focused on,
human infrastructure.
And so, $650 billion, no new
money spent, no tax increases,
because you're using
the unspent COVID funds
that's already approved by
Congress and it's paid for.
There's more than a trillion
dollars unspent, sitting there,
approved, let's use that for
infrastructure, it's done.
I introduced this
piece of legislation.
The moment they started
talking about infrastructure,
I said, there is
a way to do this
without spending new money,
and without raising taxes
on the American people.
And it's there.
I'm not just rubber
stamping a no,
saying you don't get your
bridges in your ports.
I have a good
alternative solution.
But no, there's probably, I
would say a good 10 Republicans
if we don't get enough
pressure out there,
that will help get this
infrastructure bill passed.
Look, I hope I'm wrong.
- Where does, I hope
you're wrong too, (laughs)
for the record.
Where does Biden fit
into all of this,
because I just
simply cannot believe
that this man is in charge?
And if you agree with me,
who is running the
show at this point?
- He has his staff that's
absolutely running the show.
It's really sad.
I was just talking
the other day,
I was looking at the
White House schedule
for the President of
the United States,
and it says 8:30,
a virtual briefing,
10:45, another briefing,
and then that was it.
Call it a lid.
So where's Biden, I
dunno, he's napping.
He's eating his applesauce.
It's sad.
Today I saw a press conference,
and again, no questions,
because only scripted
Joe can talk,
unscripted Joe is canceled.
He's not allowed...
- Are any of the
Democrats that are willing
to talk to you on the DLD,
are they acknowledging this?
I mean, maybe none
of them are willing.
Maybe none of them talk
to you, I don't know.
- Right.
I really like Henry Cuellar.
I haven't talked
to him about Biden,
but we talk about
the border often.
He has a brother
that's border patrol,
and he serves a border district.
And he's just disgusted
at what's happening
at the Southern border.
And so I would think that
there is some frustration
in the Democrat
party, but then again,
I was at the Congressional
Baseball Game,
and I may or may not have
been starting some chat,
chance when I saw Joe Biden
come out, let's go Brandon.
But the Democrats,
they're just so excited.
"Oh my gosh, he's here.
"He's awake." (laughs)
So, I don't know, it's
really frustrating.
Even when he came to Congress
to talk to the Democrats,
we all thought he was
coming to whip the vote.
"Hey, get it together, we're
passing this infrastructure.
"We're passing the
budget reconciliation."
But he actually just came to
say, "We don't have the votes."
Nancy couldn't tell her
own conference that.
She had to drag Joe
out of The White House
to tell the conference, "Yeah,
we don't have the votes."
- Why couldn't she tell them,
'cause she's afraid
of them, you mean?
- I think there was a
big shame factor in that.
This is supposed
to be reflective
of her entire
career in Congress.
This is supposed to be it.
This is an, and
she can't get it.
- What do you think Republicans
or conservatives can do
to take the people, say that
were like me five years ago,
that were Democrats their
whole life, Progressives?
I was a Bernie
supporter in 2016.
Obviously not that way anymore.
- Poor Bernie.
They used him and now he's done.
And he just seems like
a muppet on Twitter.
He seems like a parody of
Bernie Sanders on Twitter.
But what do you think you
guys can do messaging wise,
to make all of the
disaffected liberals,
like the not crazy Progressives,
the anti identity
politics liberals,
the Bill Maher types, that
get it about free speech,
that are maybe more
libertarian in certain ways,
to say, "Hey, we're not
as scary as they think,"
'cause that's still what
I see as the big thing.
I meet so many
people that are like,
"Dave, I'm with you
on a lot of this,
"but now it seems like you're
a conservative or something.
"I don't, nobody likes that."
It's the C word.
It's the other C word basically.
- It's crazy.
It's almost worse.
- It's worse.
- Yes. (laughs)
Yes, we have to have these
open conversations with people,
because I think we've
always been the party
of tolerance and acceptance.
We're the party of freedom.
And if that doesn't
scream from the rooftops
that we want you in our party,
then I don't know what does.
You have people mocking freedom.
I had someone
respond to my Twitter
saying that,
"Freedom isn't free.
"I'll take higher gas prices
over authoritarianism any day."
Like what do you think this is?
(Dave chuckles)
It's spending $80
million on the IRS,
and doubling their agents.
And they want to sift
through your bank accounts,
to make sure that there
isn't any crime going on.
That's their focus.
- Literally $600.
Anything over $600, that's
what they wanna double
the IRS workforce for.
- Yes.
These bureaucrat
bullies to come in.
And we've already
seen what happens
when you weaponize the IRS.
They come after conservatives
after the C-word,
and it's like with Lois Lerner.
We've seen it already.
We saw even just this year,
the IRS releasing private
information about people
who donated to Republicans.
And so, what about that?
Doesn't scream authoritarianism.
And of course the
vaccine mandates.
I heard Biden say that
we have to get 44 million
more Americans vaccinated
because we have to bring unity.
What about get this or
you're fired, says unity?
It's incredible.
I've said from the
very beginning,
this is a personal decision
between you and your doctor.
Talk to your doctor.
My doctor has never
mandated anything,
but he's always given
me his best advice
and made suggestions,
made sure that I had all the
information that I needed.
And now we have
bureaucrats and politicians
making health mandates.
- Right, and also the
fact that basically
everyone's screaming that
their four mandates right now
would be against it if
orange man was president.
- Yes.
They said it when he
was in The White House.
As soon as he mentioned vaccine,
they all were up in arms.
"If this is Donald Trump's
vaccine, I ain't doing it."
- Kamala, literally said that.
- Yes!
- Joy Reid, who would
trust the CDC now.
- Right. Exactly.
And so it's all about their
narrative, their players,
and elevating them, and
where they wanna go.
- What do you think they're
really trying to accomplish
with this vaccine mandate?
Do you think they're really
trying to keep us safe?
Is that what this really is,
they're trying to keep us safe
a year and a half
later from COVID?
- I think the words of President
Reagan still ring true,
the most dangerous nine words
in the American language
is, "I'm here from the
federal government,
"and I'm here to help."
- [Dave] Yeah.
- "I'm from the
federal government,
and I'm here to help."
That is so dangerous and there
is nothing more permanent
than a temporary
government program.
Look at the TSA, we
weren't always supposed
to stick with three
ounce bottles.
That was supposed
to be temporary.
Here we are, 20 years later.
- For the record, I know there's
a lot of nice TSA people,
but maybe they're not all as
on the ball as they should be.
But then what do
you think really is,
is the goal this Chinese
social credit system?
I had Rand Paul
on two weeks ago,
he believes that's
where this is headed.
That was conspiracy Alex
Jones stuff five years ago.
- And now it's here.
- And now it seems
like it's here.
- Yes.
I see Democrats who are envious
of the Chinese Communist
Party every day.
They wanna outsource
our energy to China.
I serve on the Natural
Resource Committee,
and I'm so happy to serve
there because I told everyone
I would be their voice.
I would fight for them, I
would secure their rights,
but I promise to work for them.
And being on the Natural
Resource Committee
gives me a seat at that table.
And I have these conversations
on a regular basis
about American
energy independence,
pursuing energy dominance
right here in America.
And they want
everything outsourced.
And it only empowers
China and weakens us.
Everything about their
policies makes us weaker.
There was a man who came
into the committee room,
and he wasn't very
happy with the industry.
And he said, "I started working
at this oil and gas company,
"and we were drilling for
natural gas in North Dakota.
"And it was really hard work.
"One week, in seven days, I
worked a record 95 hours."
I was there 95 hours, what?
Like that's nothing.
So I get on there and
talk to him and said, sir,
I too remember my
first part-time job,
(Dave laughs)
but I'm not in this committee
room bragging about it.
But he went on to
say that he has seen
artificial
hyperinflation take place
when these companies
come into communities,
I live in a community
where we had a boom,
and that boom didn't
have to go away.
I've seen these schools
built, the roads,
the fire departments, the
hospitals, the colleges,
and the small
businesses that opened,
my small business that opened.
And we were able to flourish,
and having mud on your floor
meant that things were
really going good.
And people were coming in and
patronizing your business.
I saw moms not have to work,
because dad had a
good paying job.
They could raise their babies.
I was that mom for awhile.
And I've also seen
politicians step in
and regulate our
communities into poverty.
That is artificial.
Nothing about the
success was artificial,
but that regulation is,
it didn't have to happen.
And they want to outsource all
of this to China and Africa.
In Africa, we have
40,000 children mining
with their bare hands
for cobalt in the Congo,
selling it to China,
and we are buying
solar panels from them.
These not in my
backyard extremists
don't understand what's
happening with these policies,
and what condition
they're creating
for people in other countries.
And they think that they're
doing something great,
but they're not.
- Right.
Or they really
literally mean it,
"As long as it's not in my
backyard, I don't care."
- [Lauren] Yes.
- At some level.
That's the intentions part.
- Yes, no, you're exactly right.
I actually met a very, very
wealthy woman in New York.
And there was a, she
wasn't my biggest fan,
but there was a wind farm that
was going to be put literally
in her backyard,
right across the road.
Furious, "Move it down the road.
"Why don't you put it down here?
"There's nothing over there.
"Why don't you put it in this
neighborhood, not in mine."
I said, well, ma'am
you voted for this.
This is what you wanted,
but you don't want
it in your backyard.
- It's for other people.
- Yes!
- All right.
I think I only got
one more for you,
which is so with
all of this in mind,
I think a lot of people are
suddenly talking about this idea
that the future of America is
just going to be the states
kinda going their separate way.
That just if you live
in Florida or Texas,
it's gonna be very different
than if you live in California.
Maybe that's already the
way it is, you in Colorado,
or somewhere kinda
in between on that.
But do you see that sort
of as just an inevitability
and maybe that's okay?
Maybe that's sort of how
the federalist system
was supposed to work
in the first place?
- I do think that it's okay.
I don't want this authoritarian
federal government.
I wanna shrink the federal
government as much as possible.
I don't think that
there should be
a federal department
of education.
I want the federal
government out of our lives.
And we do need to get back to
states having ultimate rule.
Unfortunately, you do get
people in these positions
where they seem to
have unchecked powers.
They have emergency orders,
and they're able to shut
down small businesses.
They're able to
stifle innovation and
tax their citizens
to a point of poverty.
And so you've seen
it in California.
We're starting to
see it in Colorado.
And so, that's obviously
the negative aspect
of having states have
their own rights,
is because it can be
a really bad place
if you have bad people
making these decisions.
But then you do have the
right to move somewhere
that is more free.
Look, I don't wanna have
to move to South Dakota,
but I will move to
America if I have to.
And so...(laughs)
- I can read the subtext here.
You're looking at me like,
yeah the weather's nice
in Cali today, but what
are you doing here?
I can see it.
But you see that not necessarily
as a totally negative thing
though, because then it
does give the opportunity
for the other states?
- Absolutely.
There definitely needs
to be competition
between these states.
Let states compete
for their citizens,
to have the best people
move to their state.
There's a lot of bright
minds moving to Texas
and to Florida right now.
Companies moving
to these states,
and they're going to make
these states better places.
We have Magpul,
they used to solely
be in Colorado,
and they moved to
Wyoming because their
gun laws are better.
And they are the number
two employer in Wyoming.
They wanna come back to
Colorado, he said, "We can't,
"your gun laws are outrageous.
"It's near impossible to
have a business there.
"And the way were starting
to be taxed and regulated,
"so we're in Wyoming.
"And when things change, let
us know, we'll come back."
- Tesla just left
Cali to go to Texas.
- Yes!
- So there might
be a theme here.
- Exactly.
And so I would love for Colorado
to be an example one day,
of how free we can be.
Bringing energy development
back, and doing it cleanly.
We have that ability there,
nobody produces energy
better than we do.
And to have everything that
our founders envisioned
for our country right
there in one state,
I would love to see
that for Colorado,
and many more states all
throughout our nation.
- Congresswoman, your
work is cut out for you.
But I wish you the best of luck.
And I'm glad we
finally did this.
- Yes!
- We met once in 2019
at a Turning Point
thing for a second,
and we agreed to do a show,
and then we basically
waited two years
because we wanted
to do it in person.
So I thank you for coming in.
- Thank you so much, Dave.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety
of topics, watch our
full episode playlists,
all right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell.